The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So we were talking about
melting in two dimensions,
and the picture that
you had was something
like a triangular lattice,
which at zero temperature
has particles sitting
at precise sites--
let's say, on this
triangular lattice--
but then at finite
temperature, the particles
will to start to deform.
And the deformations were
indicated by a vector u.
And the idea was that this
is like an elastic material,
as long as we're thinking
about these long wavelength
deformations.
u and the energy
costs can be written
for an isotropic material
in two dimensions in terms
of two invariants.
And traditionally, it
is written in terms
of the so called lame
coefficients, mu and lambda.
Where this uij,
which is the strain,
is obtained by taking
derivatives of the deformation,
the iuj, and symmetrizing it.
This symmetrization essentially
eliminates an energy
at a cost for rotations.
And then because of this
simple quadratic translation
of invariant form,
we could also express
this in terms of fullier mode.
And I'm going to write the
fullier description slightly
differently than last time.
Basically, this
whole form can be
written as u plus 2 lambda over
2 q dot u tilde of q squared.
And the other term-- other than
previously I had written things
in terms of q dot
u and q squared
u squared-- we write it in terms
of q crossed with u tilde of q
squared.
Essentially, you can see that
this ratifies that they're
going to have modes that
are in the direction of q,
the longitudinal modes.
Cost is nu plus 2
lambda, and those
that are transfers or orthogonal
to the direction of q,
whose cost is just mu.
And clearly if I were
to go into real space,
this is kind of related
to a divergence of u.
And the divergence
of u corresponds
to essentially squeezing or
expanding this deformation.
So what these measures
is essentially
the cost of changing
the density.
And this combination is
related to the bark modulus.
You have that even for a liquid.
So if you have a liquid,
you try to squeeze it.
There will be a
bulk energy cost.
And this term, which in the
real space is kind of related
to kern u, you would say
is corresponding to making
the rotations.
So if you try to rotate
this material locally,
then the corresponding
sheer cost of the formation
has a cost that is indicated
by mu, the sheer modulus.
And basically what really
makes a solid is this term.
Because as I said, a liquid
also has the bark modulus,
but lacks the resistance
to try to sheer it,
which is captured by this, that
is unique and characteristic
of a solid.
So this is the energy cost.
The other part of
this whole story
is that this
structure has order.
And we can
characterize that order
which makes it distinct from a
liquid or gas a number of ways.
One was to do an
x-ray scattering,
and then you would
see the back peaks.
And really that type of
order is translational.
And you characterize that
by an order parameter.
It's kind of like
a spin that you
have in the case of a
magnet being up or down.
In this case, this
object was e to the i g
dot u-- the deformation that
you have that's on location r.
And then these g's are chosen to
be the inverse lattice vectors.
It doesn't really matter
whether I write here
u of r or the actual position.
Because the actual positions
starts at zero temperature,
we devalue r 0, such that
the dot product of that g
is a multiple of 2pi.
And so essentially,
that's what captures this.
Clearly, if I start with
a zero temperature picture
and just move this
around, the phase
of this order parameter
over here will change,
but it will be the
same across the system.
And so this is long
range correlation that
is present at zero
temperature, you
can ask what happens to
it at finite temperature.
So we can look at the row
g at some position, row g
star at some other position.
And so that was related to
exponential of minus g squared
over 2-- something
like u squared
x, or u of x minus 0 squared.
And what we saw
was that this thing
had a characteristic that it
was falling off with distance
according to some
kind of power law.
The exponent of this power
law, when calculated,
clearly is related
to this g squared.
Because this is the quantity
that goes logarithmically.
And so the answer was
g squared over 4 pi.
Heat was dependent on these
two modes being present.
So you have nu 2 nu plus lambda,
and then 2 nu plus lambda.
You had a form such as this.
Now this result was
obtained as long
as we were treating this
field, u, as just the continuum
field that satisfies this.
And this result is
really different, also,
from the expectation that
at very high temperature
the particle in a liquid
should not know anything
about the particle
further out in the liquid,
as long as they're beyond
some small correlation links.
So we expect this to
actually decay exponentially
at high temperatures.
And we found that
we could account
for that by addition
of these locations,
can cause a transition
to a high temperature
phase in which row g, row
g star, between x and 0,
decays exponentially.
As opposed to this
algebraic behavior,
indicating that these
locations-- once you
go to sufficiently
high temperature,
such that the entropy of
creating and rearranging
these dislocations overcomes
the large cost of creating them
in the first place,
then you'll have
this absence of
translational order,
and some kind of exponential
decay of this order parameter.
So at this stage, you may
feel comfortable enough
to say that addition
of these dislocation
causes our solid to melt
and become a liquid.
Now, I indicated,
however, that the sun also
has an orientational role.
What I could do is-- at
each location in the solid,
I can ask how much has
the angle been deformed,
and look at the bond angle.
So maybe this
particle moved here,
and this particle moved here.
Somewhere else, the
particles may have
moved in a different fashion.
And the angle that
was originally,
say, along the x direction,
had rotated somewhere else.
And clearly, again,
at zero temperature,
I can look at the correlations
of this angular order,
and they would be the
same across the system.
I can ask what happens when
I include these deformations
and then the dislocations.
So in the same way that we
defined the translational order
parameter, I can define an
orientational order parameter.
Let's call it sci
at some location, r,
which is e to the i.
Theta at that location r--
Except that when I look
at the triangular lattice,
it may be that the triangles
have actually rotated
by 60 degrees or 120 degrees.
And I can't really tell whether
I clicked once, zero times,
twice, et cetera.
So because of this symmetry of
the original lattice on their
on their theta going to
theta plus 2 pi over 6,
I have to use something
like this that will not
be modified if I make
this transformation,
even at zero temperature.
If I miscount some angle by 60
degrees, this will become fine.
Now I want to calculate the
correlations of this theta
from one part of this system
to another part of the system.
So for that, what
I need to do is
to look at the
relationship between theta
and the distortion field,
u, that I told you before.
Now you can see that right
on the top right corner
I took the distortion field,
and I took it's derivative,
and then symmetrized
the result in pencil.
And that symmetrization
actually removes any rotation
that I would have.
So in order to bring
back the notation,
I just have to put a minus sign.
And indeed, one can show that
the distortion or displacement
u or r across my
system-- let's call it
u of x-- leads to a
corresponding angular
distortion, theta, at x, which
is minus one half-- let's
call it z hat dotted
with curve of u.
So if, rather than doing
the i u j plus d j u i,
if I put a minus sign,
you can see that I
have the structure of a curve.
In two dimensions,
actually curve
would be something that
would be pointing only
along the z direction.
And so I just make
a scale on my dot,
without taking that
in the z direction.
And so you can do
some distortion,
and convince yourself
that for each distortion
you will get an
angle that is this.
AUDIENCE: Do we need some
kind of thermalization
to fix the dimensions of this?
Because that can go u has
dimensions of fields, and u--
PROFESSOR: I'm only talking
about two dimensions.
And in any case,
you can see that u
is a distortion--
is a displacement--
the gradient is reduced
by the displacement,
so this thing is
dimensionless as long as you
have these dimensions.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: That's a 2, right?
Not a c?
PROFESSOR: That's a 2.
It's the same 2 that I have for
the definition of the strain.
Rather than a plus,
you put a minus.
AUDIENCE: So can
we think of these
as two sets of Goldstone
modes, or is that not a way
to interpret it?
Is it like two order parameters?
I mean, you have a think
that has u dependence, but--
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's look
at this picture over here.
You do have two sets of
Goldstone modes corresponding
to longitudinal transfers.
You can see that this
curve is the thing
is that I call the angle.
So if you like, you can
put the angle over here.
But the difference between
putting an angle here,
and this term, is that
in terms of the angle,
there is no q dependence.
So it is not a ghost.
Because the cost of making a
distortion of wave number q
does not vanish as
q squared works.
All right, so then I can look
at the correlation between, say,
sci of x, sci star of zero.
And what I will be calculating
is expectation value of e
to the i 6.
And then I will have
this factor of--
So let me write it
in this fashion.
Theta of x minus theta of 0.
Since u is Gaussian
distributed, theta
in the Gaussian distributor.
So for any Gaussian
distributed entity,
we can write the
exponential of e
to the something as its average
as exponential of minus 1/2
the average of whatever
is in the exponent.
So I will get 36 divided by 2.
I do have the expectation
value of delta theta squared.
But delta theta is related
up to this factor of 1/4
to some expectation
value of kern u.
So I would need to calculate
kern mu at x minus kern u
at 0, the whole thing squared
with the Gaussian average.
Now, this entity--
clearly what I can do
is to go back and
look at these things
in terms of Fourier space,
rather than position space.
So this becomes an integral
d 2 q 2 pi to the d.
I will get e to the
i q dot x minus 1.
And then I have something
like q cross u tilde of q.
And I have to do that twice.
When I do that twice, I find
that the different q's are
uncorrelated.
So I will get, rather than
two of these integrals, one
of these integrals.
And because the q and q prime
are said to be the same,
the product of those two
factors will be the integral 2
minus 2 cosine of q dot x
term that we are used to.
And so that's where the
x dependence appears.
And then I need the
average of q cross mu of q.
And that I can read off
the beta [INAUDIBLE],
root the energy over here.
You can see that there
is a Gaussian cost
for q plus u of q
squared, which is simply
1 of a lingering variance.
So basically, this term
you'll the sum of 1 over u.
Now the difference between
all of the calculations
that we were doing previously,
as was asked regarding
Goldstone modes-- if I was just
looking at u squared, which
is what I was doing
up here, I would
need to put another factor of
1 over q squared [INAUDIBLE].
And then I would have
the coulomb integral that
would grow logarithmically.
But here you can see that
the whole thing-- the cosine
integrated against
the constant--
will average out to 0.
So I will think you
have 2 over u times
this integral is a constant.
So the whole thing,
at the end of the day,
is exponential of-- that
becomes a 9 divided by 2.
There's a factor
of 1 over the mu,
and then I have twice the
integral of d 2 q over 2 pi
squared.
Which is-- you can
convince yourself
simply the density of the
system a number of times.
So as opposed to the
translational order, which
was decaying as above
our lot, then we
include the phonon modes.
When we include
these phonon modes,
we find that the orientational
order decays much more weakly.
So that was falling off as
I went further and further.
This, as I go
further and further,
eventually reaches a
constant that is less than 1,
but it is something.
Using conversely
proportional to temperature--
so as I go to 0
temperature, these go to 1.
And basically because
this order parameter,
with respect to--
well, this measure
of distortion with respect
to that measure of distortion
has an additional
factor of gradient.
I will get an additional
factor of q squared, and then
everything changes accordingly.
So orientational order
is much more robust.
This phase that we were
calling the analogue of a two
dimensional solid had only
quasi long range order.
The long range order was
decaying as a power law.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is n dependent
on the position, or--
PROFESSOR: No.
So basically, if you were to
remember the number of points
it should be the same as the
number of allowed fullier
modes.
And this goes to
an integral-- 2 q
over 2 pi squared-- when I put
the area in two dimensions.
So the integral over
whatever [INAUDIBLE]
zone you have over
the fullier modes
is the same thing as
the number of points
that you have in the original
lattice, divided by area,
or 1 over the size of one
of those triangles squared.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where is the x
dependent in that expression?
PROFESSOR: OK, the x
dependence basically
disappears because you integrate
over the cosine of q x.
And if x is sufficiently large,
those fluctuations disappear.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so we're really
looking at the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
So at short distances,
there are going
to be some oscillations
or whatever.
But it gradually-- we are
interested in the long distance
behavior.
At very short
distances, I can't even
use the continuum
description for things
that are three or
lattice spacings apart.
So maybe I should explicitly
say that this is usually
called quasi long range order,
versus this dependence, which
is two long ranges.
So given that this is more
robust than these forum-like
fluctuations, the
next question is, well
does it completely disappear
when I include these locations.
So again, this calculation,
based on Gaussian's, relies
on just the fullier modes of
that line that I have up there.
It does not include the
dislocations, which, in order
to properly account,
you saw that we
need to look at a collections
of these locations appearing
at different positions
on the lattice.
And they had these vectorial
nature of the fullier
interactions among them.
So presumably, when I
go into the base where
these locations unbind--
and by unbinding--
as I said, in the
low temperature
picture of the
dislocations, they
should appear very
close to each other
because it is costly to separate
them by an amount that grows
invariably in the separation.
In the unbound phase, you
have essentially a gas
of dislocations that
can be anywhere.
So the picture here
now is that indeed this
is a phase, that if I just
focus on the dislocations,
there is a whole bunch of them.
In a triangular
lattice, they could
be pointing in any one of three
directions, plus or minus.
And then there is certainly
an additional contribution
to the angle that comes from the
presence of these dislocations.
So you calculate-- if you
have a dislocation that
has inverse b, let's say at the
origin, what kind of angular
distortion does it cause.
And you find that it goes
like v dot x, divided
by the absolute value of x.
This is for one dislocation.
This is the theta that you
would get for that dislocation
at location x.
Essentially, you
can see that if I
were to replace the u that
I have here with the u that
was caused by dislocation,
you would get something
like this formula.
Because remember the u that
was caused by dislocation
was something like the
gradient of the log potential.
It's kind of hard to
work, but maybe I'll
make an attempt to write it.
So let's take a
gradient of theta.
Gradient of theta, if
I use that formula,
you would say, OK, I
have minus 1/2 z hat dot
kern of something.
And if I take a gradient of the
kern, the answer should be 0.
But that's as long as this
u is a well defined object.
And our task was to say
that this u, then you
have these dislocations,
is not a well defined
object, in the sense
that you take the kern,
and the gradient
then you would get 0.
So essentially, I will
transport the gradient
all the way over here,
and the part of u
that will survive that is
the one that is characterized
by this dislocation feat.
Now, you can see
that this object
kind of looks like a
Laplacian of this distortion.
It's two the derivatives
of this distortion field
that had this logarithm in it.
And when you take two
derivatives of a logarithm,
you get the delta function.
So if you do things
correctly, you
will find that this answer
here becomes a sum over i
v i delta function
of x minus xi.
So basically, each dislocation
at location x i-- again,
depending on its v being
in each direction--
gives a contribution to
the gradient of theta.
And if I were to take the
gradient of the expression
that I have over here, the
gradient of this object
is also-- this is like
the field that you
have for the
logarithmic potential--
will give you the data function.
So that's where the
similarity comes.
So the full answer
comes out to be--
if you have a sum
over the dislocations,
the sum over the distortion
fields that each one of them
is causing-- and you will
have a form such as this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Should the
denominator be squared?
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
The potential goes
logarithmically.
The field, which is the
gradient of the potential,
falls off as 1 over separation.
So since I put the
separation out there,
I have to put the
separation squared.
So you can see that the
singular part, the part that
arises from dislocations-- if
I have a soup of dislocations,
I can figure out what theta is.
Now what I did look
for-- actually, I
was kind of hinting at that-- if
I take the gradient of theta--
and I forgot to put
the factor of 1/2pi
here-- does the 4 vertices
that had charged to pi--
I had the potential.
That was 1/r.
So for dislocations
it becomes d/2pi.
If I take the gradient,
then the gradient translates
to sum over pi, the i
data function of x minus x
i-- the expression that I
have written over there.
And if I do the
fullier transform,
you see what I did over
here was essentially
to look at theta
in fullier space.
So let's do something
similar here.
So when I do the fullier
transform of this,
I will get pi q-- the fullier
transform of this angular feat.
And on the right hand
side, what I would get
is essentially the
fullier transform
of the field of dislocations.
So I have defined my v of q to
be sum over i into the i q dot
position of the i
dislocation, the vector that
characterizes the dislocation.
And it would make
sense to also tap
into the normalization
that gives 1
over the square root of area.
If you don't do that,
then at some other point
you have to worry about
the normalization.
So if I just multiply
both sides by q--
and I think I forgot the
minus sign throughout,
which is not that important--
but theta tilde of q
becomes i q dot b of
q, divided-- maybe
I should've been calling this
b tilde-- divided by q squared.
So this is important.
Essentially, you take the
collection of dislocations
in this picture
and you calculate
what the fullier transform
is, call that the tilde of q.
Essentially, you divide
by 1 factor of q,
and you can get the
corresponding angle of feat.
Now what I needed
to evaluate for here
was the average of theta
tilde of q squared.
And you can see that if I
write this explicitly, let's
say, q i for be tilde i 4,
then the two of them I will
get q beta b tilde of beta.
And then I would
have a q to the side.
And the average over
here becomes the average
over all contributions
of these dislocations
that I can put across my system.
Now, explicitly I'm interested
in the limit where q goes to 0.
So these things depend on q.
What I'm interested
in is the limit
as q goes to 0, especially
what happens to this average.
It becomes-- multiplying two
of these things together--
actually, in the limit
where q goes to 0,
what I have is the sum
over all of the b's.
So in the limit
where q goes to 0,
this becomes an integral or sum.
It doesn't matter which
one of them I write.
q has gone to 0,
so I basically need
to look at the average of
the alpha of x, the beta of x
[INAUDIBLE], divided by area.
So what is there
in the numerator?
We can see that in the
numerator, sq goes to 0.
What I'm looking at is the sum
of all of these dislocations
that I have in the system.
Now the average up the
sum is 0, because in all
of our calculations, we've been
restricting the configurations
that we moved from.
Because if I go
beyond that strategy,
it's going to cost too much.
But what I'm looking
at is not the average
of b, which is 0, but
the average of b squared,
which is the variance.
So essentially I have a system
that has a large area, a.
It is on average neutral.
And the question is, what is
the variance of the net charge.
And my claim is that the
variance of the net charge
is, by central limit theorem,
proportional to the area--
actually, it is proportional
to the units that are
independent from each other.
So roughly I would expect that
in this high temperature phase,
I have a correlation that is c.
And within each portion of
side c, will be neutral.
But when I go within things
that are more than c apart,
there's no reason to
maintain the strategy.
So overall I have something
like throwing coins,
but at each one of
them, the average
is 0, with probability
being up or down.
But when I look at the
variance for the entire thing,
the average will be
proportional to the area
in units of these things that
are independent of each other.
It was from the normalization
factor of 1 over area.
And these, really, I should
write as a proportionality,
because I don't
know precisely what
the relationship between
these independent sides
that correlation [INAUDIBLE].
But they have to be
roughly proportional.
So what do you compute?
You compute that
the limit as q goes
to 0, of the average of my
theta tilde of q squared
is a structure such as this.
I forgot to put one
more thing here.
I don't expect to
be any correlations
between the x
component and the y
component of this
answer-- the variance,
the covariance of the
dislocations in one
direction and the
other direction--
so I put the delta
function there.
If I put this over here,
I would get the q squared
divided by q to the 4th.
So I will get a 1
over4 q squared.
And I have the c squared and
then some unknown coefficient
up here.
So it's interesting,
because we started
without thinking about
dislocations, just in terms
of the distortion field.
And we said that this object
is related to the angle.
And indeed, we had
this distortion,
that energy cost of distortions
is proportional to angle
squared.
And that angle, therefore,
is not the Goldstone mode
because it doesn't
go like q squared.
Now we go to this
other phase now,
with dislocations
all over the place,
and we calculate the expectation
value of theta squared.
And it looks like it
came from a theory that
was like Goldstone modes.
So you would say that once
I am in this phase, where
the dislocations are unbound,
there is an effective energy
cost for these
changes in angle that
is proportional to the
radiant of the angle squared.
So that means fullier space,
this would go to k a over 2,
integral into q 2 pi squared,
q squared theta tilde of q
squared.
So that if you had this
theory, you would definitely
say that the expectation value
of theta tilde of q squared
is 1 over k a q squared.
The variance is k
a q squared invers.
You compare those two things
and you find that once
the dislocations have
unbound, and there
is a correlation lend
that essentially tells you
how far the dislocations
are talking to each other
and maintaining neutrality,
that there is exactly
an effective stiffness,
like a Goldstone note,
for angular distortions, that
is proportional to c squared.
And hence, if I were to look
at the orientation of all
their correlations,
I would essentially
have something like expectation
value of theta q squared,
which is 1 over q squared.
If I fully transform
that, I get the log.
And so I will get
something that falls off
in the distance to some
other exponent, if I recall
[INAUDIBLE].
If I have a true
liquid-- in a liquid,
again, maybe in a
neighborhood of seven
or eight particles,
neighbors, et cetera,
they talk to each other and the
orientations are correlated.
But then I go from
one part of the liquid
to another part of
the liquid, there
is no correlation
between bond angles.
I expect these things
to decay exponentially.
So what we've established
is that neither the phonon
nor the dislocations
are sufficient to give
the exponential decay that
you expect for the bond.
So this object has
quasi long range order,
versus what I expect to
happen in the liquid, which
is exponential of
minus x over psi.
So the unbinding of
dislocations gives rise
to the new phase of matter
that has this quasi long range
order in the orientations.
It has no positional order.
It's a kind of a liquid crystal
that is called a hexatic.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So your correlation
where you got 1 over k q
squared, doesn't that assume
that you're allowing the angle
to vary in minus [INAUDIBLE]
when you do your averaging?
What about the restriction--
PROFESSOR: OK, so what is the
variance of the angle here?
There's a variance of the angle
that is controlled by this 1
over k a.
So if I go back and calculate
these in real space,
I will find that if I look at
theta at location x minus theta
at location 0, the
answer is going to go
like 1 over k logarithm x.
So what it says
is that if things
are close enough to each other--
and this is in units of 1/a--
up to some factor, let's
say log 5, et cetera.
So I don't go all
the way to infinity.
The fluctuations in angle are
inversely set by a parameter
that we see as I approach
right after the transition is
very large.
So in the same sense
that previously
for the positional
correlations I
had the temperature being small
and inverse temperature being
large, limiting the size of
the translational fluctuations,
here the same thing happens for
the bond angle fluctuations.
Close to the transitions,
they are actually small.
So the question
that you asked, you
could have certainly
also asked over here.
That is, when I'm thinking
about the distortion field,
the distortion field is
certainly going to be limited.
If it becomes as big as this,
then it doesn't make sense.
So given that,
what sense or what
justification do I have
in making these Gaussian
integrals?
And the answer is
that while it is true
that it is fluctuating, as
I go to low temperature,
the degree of fluctuations
is very small.
So effectively
what I have is that
I have to integrate over
some finite interval
a function that kind
of looks like this.
And the fact that I replaced
that with an integration
from minus infinity to infinity
rather than from minus a
to a just doesn't matter.
So we know that ultimately
we should get this,
but so far we've only got
this, so what should we do?
Well, we say OK, we
encountered this difficulty
before in something that looked
like an angle in the xy model--
that low temperature
had power-law decay,
whereas we knew that
at high temperatures
they would have to
have exponential decay.
And what we said was that we
need these topological defects
in angle.
So what you need-- topological
defects-- or in our case,
theta is a bond angle.
And these topological defects
in the bond angle have a name.
They're called disconnections.
And very roughly they correspond
to something like this.
Suppose this is the center
one of these discriminations,
and then maybe
next to this, here
I have locally at the distance
r-- if I look at a point,
I would see that the bonds
that connect it to its neighbor
have an orientation such as the
one that I have indicated over
here.
Now what I want to do is, as I
go around and make a circuit,
that this angle theta
that I have here to be 0,
rotates and comes
back up to 60 degrees.
So essentially what I
do is I take this line
and I gradually shift it
around so that by the time
I come back, I have
rotated by 60 degrees.
It's kind of hard
for me to draw that,
but you can imagine
what I have to do.
So what I need to do
is to have the integral
over a circuit that encloses
this discrimination such
that when I do a d s dotted
with the gradient of the bond
orientational angle,
I come back to pi over
6 times some integer.
And again, I expect the
[INAUDIBLE] dislocations that
correspond to minus plus 1.
Then the cost of
these is obtained
by taking this distortion
fee, gradient of theta,
whose magnitude at a distance r
from the center of this object
is going to be 1 over 2
pi r times pi over 6 times
whatever this integer n is.
And then if I substitute
this 1 over r behavior
in this expression, which
is the effective energy
of this entity, I will
get the logarithmic cost
for making a single
disclination.
Which means that
at low temperature,
I have to create
disclination pairs.
And then there will be
an effective interaction
between disclination
pairs, that is
[INAUDIBLE] in exactly the
same way that we calculated
for the x y model.
So up to just this minor change
that the charge of a refect
is reduced by a factor
of six, this theory
is identical the theory of
the unbinding of the x y
model [INAUDIBLE] defects.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is it pi
over 6 and not 2 pi over 6?
PROFESSOR: You are right.
It should be 2 pi over 6.
Thank you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So when
you were saying that
the-- so the distance of this
hexatic phase would require
the dislocations to occur
to [INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE]
orientational defects.
Is there an analogous
case where--
I guess you can't have
dislocations in the orientation
without the dislocation--
PROFESSOR: So if you try
to make these objects
in the original case, in
the origin of lattice,
you will find that their
cost grows actually
like l squared log l, as
opposed to dislocations,
whose cost only grows as log l.
So these entities are
extremely unlikely to occur
in the original system.
If you sort of go back
and ask what they actually
correspond to, if you have a
picture that you have generated
on the computer,
they're actually
reasonably easy to identify.
Because the centers
of these disclinations
correspond to
having points, that
have, rather than 6
neighbors, 5 or 7 neighbors.
So you generate the picture,
and you find mostly you have
neighborhoods with 6 neighbors,
and then there's a site where
there's 5 neighbours,
and another site that's 7
neighbors.
5 and 7 come more
or less in pairs,
and you can identify these
disclination pairs reasonably
easy.
So at the end of the day,
the picture that we have
is something like this.
We are starting with
the triangular lattice
that I drew at the
beginning, and you're
increasing temperature.
We're asking what happens.
So this is 0 temperature.
Close to 0 temperature,
what we have
is an entity that has
translational quasi
long range order.
So this quantity goes like 1
over x to this power a to g.
Whereas the orientations
go to a constant.
Now, this a to g is
there because there's
a shear modulus.
And so throughout this phase,
I have a shear modulus.
The parameter that
I'm calling u,
I had scaled inversely
with temperature.
So I have this
shear modulus u that
diverges once we scale
by temperature as 1
over temperature.
But then as I come down, the
reduction is more than one
over temperature
because I will have
this effect of dislocations
appearing in pairs,
and the system becomes softer.
And eventually you
will find that there's
a transition temperature at
which the shear modulus drops
down to 0.
And we said that
near this transition,
there is this behavior
that mu approaches mu
c, whatever it is,
with something-- let's
call this t 1.
T 1 minus t to this
exponent mu bar
which was planned to be 6963.
Now, once we are beyond
this temperature t 1, then
our positional correlations
decay exponentially
at some correlation, like c.
And this c is
something that diverges
on approaching this transition.
So basically I have a c that
goes up here to infinity.
And the fact that if
we calculate the c,
it diverges according to
this strange formula that
was 1 over t minus t
1 to this exponent mu
bar Very strange
type of divergence.
But then, associated with
the presence of this c
is the fact that when you
look at the orientational
correlations, they don't
decay as an exponential
but as a power-law 8 of c.
And this 8 of c is related to
this k a, and falls off as 1
over c squared.
So here it diverges as you
approach this transition.
Now, as we go further
and further on,
the disclinations will
appear-- disclinations
with [INAUDIBLE]
resolve of the angles
to be parallel to each other.
And there's another
transition that
is [INAUDIBLE], at which this is
going to suddenly go down to 0.
And close to here,
we have that a to c
reaches the critical
value of 1/4 v
to square root
of-- let's call it
t 2-- v the square
root singularity.
And then finally we have
the ordinary liquid phase,
where additionally I will find
that psi 6 of x psi star 6 of 0
decays exponentially.
Let's call it psi 6.
And this psi 6 is
something that will diverge
of this transition as an
exponential of minus 1
over square root of t minus t2.
So this is the current
scenario of how
melting could occur for a system
of particles in two dimensions.
If it is a continuous
phase transition,
it has to go through
these two transitions
with the intermediate
exotic phase.
Of course, it is also
possible-- and typically people
were seeing numerically
when they were doing hearts,
spheres, et cetera,
that there is
a direct transition from here
to here, which is discontinuous,
like you have in
three dimensions.
So that's an area of a
discontinuous transition
that is not ruled out.
But if you have
continuous transitions,
it has to have this intermediate
phase in [INAUDIBLE].
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
so the red one is mu.
The yellow one is theta psi, and
the purple one is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The correlation,
then, that I would put here.
So they are three
different entities.
So throughout the
course, we have
been thinking about
systems that are
described by some kind of
an equilibrium probability
distribution.
So what we did not
discuss is how the system
comes to that equilibrium.
So we're going to now very
briefly talk about dynamics,
and the specific
type of dynamics
that is common to
condensed matter
systems at finite
temperature, which I
will call precipative dynamics.
And the prototype of this
is a Brownian particle
that I will briefly
review for you.
So what you have is that
you have a particle that
is within some
kind of a solvent,
and this particle
is moving around.
So you would say,
let's for simplicity
actually focus on
the one direction, x.
And you would say that
the mass of the particle
times its acceleration
is equal to the forces
that it's experiencing.
The forces-- well, if you
are moving in a fluid,
you are going to be
subject to some kind
of a dissipative force
which is typically
portional to your velocity.
If you, for example,
solve for the hydrodynamic
of a sphere in a
fluid, you find that mu
is related to
viscosity inversely
to the size of the
particle, et cetera.
But that behavior is generic.
You're not going be
thinking about that.
Now suppose that
additionally I put
some kind of an optical
trap, or something that tries
to localize this potential.
So then there would be
an additional force v
2, the derivative of the
potential with respect to x.
And then we are talking
about Brownian particles.
Brownian particles are
constantly jiggling.
So there is also a random force
that is a function of time.
Now we are going to be
interested in the dynamics that
is very much controlled
by the dissipation term.
And acceleration we can forget.
And if we are in that limit,
we can write the equation
as mu-- I can sort of rearrange
it slightly as-- actually,
let me change location to this.
So that the eventual
velocity x dot
is going to be proportional
to the external force.
mu the coefficient
that is the mobility.
So mu essentially relates
the force to the velocity.
Of course, this is
the average force.
And there is a fluctuating
part, so essentially, I
call mu times this to be
the a times function of t.
Now, if I didn't have
this external force,
the fluctuations of the
particles would be diffusive.
And you can convince
yourself that you
can get the diffusive result
provided that you relate
the correlations of this
force that fluctuating
and have 0 average, the
diffusion constant d
of the particle in the medium
through delta of t minus t.
So if their track was not there,
you solve of this equation
without the track and find that
the prohibitive distribution
for x grows as a Gaussian whose
width grows with time, as d t.
d therefore must be
the diffusion constant.
Now, in the presence
of the potential,
this particle will
start to fluctuate.
Eventually if you
wait long enough,
there is a probability
that it will be here,
a probability to
be somewhere else.
So at long enough times,
there's a probability p
of x to find the particle.
And you expect
that t of x will be
proportional to exponential
of minus v of x divided
by whatever the temperature is.
And you can show that in
order to have this occur,
you need to relate mu and d
through the so called Einstein
relation.
So this is a brief review
of Brownian particles.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The average and
time correlation of eta
can be found by saying
the potential is 0, right?
PROFESSOR: Mm hmm.
AUDIENCE: Those
will still be true
even if the potential
is not 0, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So I just wanted to have an
idea of where this d comes from.
But more specifically, this
is the important thing.
That if at very
long times you want
to have a probability
distribution coming
from this equation, that
has the Boltzmann form
with k t, the coefficients
of mu and the noise,
you have to relate through the
so called Einstein relation.
And once you do
that, this result
is true no matter how
complicated this v of x is.
So in general, for a
complicated v of x,
you won't be able to solve
this equation analytically.
You can only do it numerically.
Yet you are guaranteed that
this equation with this noise
correlator will have
asymptotically a probability
distribution of [INAUDIBLE].
The problem that we
have been looking at all
along is something different.
Let's say you have, let's
say, a piece of magnet
or some other system
that we characterize,
let's say, by something m of x.
Again, you can do it for vector,
but for simplicity, let's do it
for the scalar case.
So we know, or we have stated,
that subject to the symmetries
of the system, I
know the probability.
For some configuration of this
field is governed by a form,
let's say, that has
Landau Ginzburg character.
So that has been
our starting point.
We have said that I have a
prohibitive distribution that
is of this form.
So that statement is kind
of like this statement.
But the way that I
came to that statement
was to say that there
was a degree of freedom
x, the position of the particle,
that was fluctuating subject
to forces and external
variables from the particles
of the fluid, that was given
by this so called Langevin
equation.
So I had a time
dependent prescription
that eventually went to the
Boltzmann way that I wanted.
Here I have started with
the final Boltzmann weight.
And the question is, can
I think about a dynamics
for a field that will
eventually give this state.
So there are lots and
lots of different dynamics
that I can impose.
But I want to look
at the dynamics that
is closest to the Brownian
particle that I wrote,
and that's where this
word dissipative comes.
So among the universe of
all possible dynamics,
I'm going to look at one
that has a linear time
derivative for the field n.
So this is the
analog of the x dot.
And so I write that it is
equal to some coefficient,
that with their minds,
the ease with which
that particle-- well the
field of that location x
changes as a function of the
forces that is exerted on it.
I assume that mu is the
same across my system.
So here I'm already assuming
there's no x dependence.
This system is uniform.
And then there was a d v by d x.
So v was ultimately the
thing that was appearing
in the Boltzmann weight.
So clearly the analog
of the v that I have
is this Landau Ginzburg.
So I will do a function of the
derivative of this quantity
that I will call beta h,
with respect to m of x.
Again, over there, I
had one variable, x.
You can imagine that I could
have had a system where
two particles, x 1 and x 2, also
have an interaction among them.
Then the equation that I
would have had over there
would be the force that
is acting on particle 1,
by taking the total
potential-- which
is the external potential
plus the potential that
comes from the inter
particle interaction.
So I would have to
take a derivative
of the net potential energy
v, divided with respect
to either x 1 or x 2
to calculate the force
on the first one
or the second one.
So here for a
particular configuration
m of the field
across the system,
if I'm interested in the
dynamics of this position x,
I have to take this total
internal potential energy,
and take the
derivative with respect
to the variable that is
sitting on that side.
So that's why this
is a functional
derivative of this end.
And then I will have
to put a noise, eta.
Well, again, if I had
multiple particles,
I would subject each one of
them to an independent noise.
So at each location, I
have an independent noise.
So the noise is a
function of time,
but it is also wearing
across my system.
So if I take that form and do
the functional derivative--
so if I take the derivative
with respect to m of x,
I have to take the
derivative of these objects.
So I will have minus derivative
of t m squared is t m.
The u m to the 4th is
4 u m q, and so forth.
Once I have gotten
rid of these terms,
then I would have terms
that depend on the gradient.
So I would have minus the
derivative of this object
with respect to the gradient.
So here I would get
k gradient of m.
And then the next term would
be Laplacian derivative,
with respect to Laplacian.
So I would put l Laplacian
of m, and so forth
with the methodologies of
taking function derivatives.
And then I have the noise.
So this leads to
an equation which
is called a time
dependent, Landau Ginzberg.
Because we started with
the Landau Ginzberg weight,
and this equation,
as we see shortly,
subject to similar restrictions
as we had before, will give us,
eventually, this
probability distribution.
This is a difficult
equation in the same sense
that the original
Landau Ginzberg
is difficult to look at
correlations, et cetera.
This is a nonlinear equation,
causes various difficulties,
and we need approaches
to be able to deal
with the difficult,
non linealities.
So what we did for
the Landau Ginzburg
was to initially get insights
and simplify the system
by focusing on the linearized
or Gaussian version.
So let's look at the version
of this equation that
is linearized.
And when it is linearized, what
I have on the left hand side
is d m by d t.
What I have on the
right hand side is mu.
I have t m.
I got rid of the
non linear term,
so the next term that I will
have will be k Laplacian of m,
and then will be minus l 4th
derivative of m, and so forth.
And then there will be
a noise [INAUDIBLE].
One thing that I
can immediately do
is to go to fullier transform.
So m of x goes to m theta of q.
And if I do that, but not
fullier transform in time,
I will get that the time
derivative of m tilde of q
is essentially what I have here.
And I forgot the minus
that I have here.
So this minus is important.
And then this becomes negative,
this becomes positive.
So that when I go fullier
transform, what I will get
is minus t plus k q squared plus
l q to the 4th, and so forth.
And tilde of q with
this mu out front.
And then the fullier
transform of what my noise is.
First thing to note is that
even in the absence of noise,
there is a set of
relaxation times.
That is, for eta it was to 0.
Or in general, I would
have n tilde of q and p.
I can solve this
equation kind of simply.
It is the m by d t is
some constant times
n-- let's call it
gama of q-- which
has dimensions of 1 over time.
So I can call that
1 over tau of q.
If I didn't have
noise, if I started
with some original
value at time 0,
it is going to
decay exponentially
with this characteristic time.
And once I have
noise, it is actually
easy to convince yourself
that the answer is
0 2 t d t prime e to the minus
this gamma of q or inversify.
Tau of q times eta
of q i t prime.
So you see that you have a
hierarchy of relaxation times,
ta of q, which are 1 over u t
plus k q squared, and so forth,
which scale in two limits.
Either the wavelength lambda,
which is the inverse of q
is much larger than the
correlation length--
and the correlation
length of this model
you have seen to be the
square root of t over k,
square root of k over
t-- or the other limit,
where lambda is
much less than c.
In this limit,
where we are looking
at modes that are much shorter
than the correlation length,
this term is dominant.
This becomes 1 over
mu k q squared.
In the other limit, it goes
to a constant 1 over u t.
So this linear equation
has a whole bunch
of modes that can
be characterized
by their wavelength
or their wave number.
You find that the
short wavelength modes
have this characteristic, time,
that becomes longer and longer
as the wavelength increases.
So if you make the
wavelength twice as large,
and you want to relax a
system that is linearly
twice as large, this says that
it will take 4 times longer.
Because the answer goes
like lambda squared.
Whereas eventually you reach the
size of the correlation length.
Once you are beyond the size
of the correlation length,
it doesn't matter.
It's the same time.
But the interesting
thing, of course, to us
is that there are
phase transitions that
are continuous.
And close to that
phase transition,
the correlation length
goes to infinity.
Which means that the relaxation
time also will go to infinity.
So according to
this theory, there's
a particular divergence
as 1 over t minus t c.
But it will be modified, and
as I will discuss next time,
this is only-- even within
to dissipative class--
one type of dynamics
that you can have.
And there are
additional dynamics,
and this system
characterizes criticality
as single universality
class in statics.
There are many dynamic
universality classes that
correspond to this same static.